-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
What a great time to be in
New York City.
Fall in New York!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's nothing better.
It's that special time when
all the vomit puddles
on the sidewalk go from
hard seltzer to hard cider.
You know what I'm saying?
It's very exciting.
Well, guys,
everybody's talking about this.
At a big Tesla event,
Elon Musk unveiled the prototype
for a humanoid robot.
Yeah, and the robot showed off
its human-like
walking skills when it entered.
Watch this.
Yeah. Yeah, that's great.
[ Laughter ]
-What the...
-Billions of dollars
on a robot that walks like
it just ate Chipotle.
It's like...
♪♪
-Guac extra.
-Some news from overseas.
I heard that today
at the Vatican,
Pope Francis met
with Apple C.E.O. Tim Cook.
I guess when you're the pope
and have tech issues,
that's who they send.
Meanwhile,
Adam and Eve were like,
"Oh, so now
we're cool with apples?
Interesting. Okay, good.
Interesting."
I saw that Kim Kardashian
has agreed to pay a $1.3 million
fine for
promoting cryptocurrency
without saying
that she was being paid.
$1.3 million.
Fining Kim Kardashian
$1.3 million
is like giving Elon Musk
a parking ticket.
He's like, "Oh..."
I read that due to inflation,
single Americans
are going on fewer dates.
You know it's bad when
your date says,
"This could have been a Zoom."
Yep, thanks to inflation,
single people are
going on fewer dates,
so to make up for it,
we're all going to go on a date
right now together.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's time for "Togethering."
Here we go.
♪♪
I'm worried that
you're hotter than me.
Uh, hi.
I'll have
the second-cheapest wine.
Thank you.
Wow, this is
a very expensive restaurant.
I might have
forgotten my wallet.
I haven't decided yet.
Thanks.
What's that?
Sure, we can split something.
We'll split the soup.
I'll have the upper half,
and you'll have the lower.
Just so you know,
the bathroom was out of
toilet paper before I went.
Just wanted...
How many siblings do you have?
Three? Me too!
Oh, my God! That's so crazy.
What's your middle name?
No, never mind. It's too soon.
Have you seen
"House of the Dragon"?
I haven't.
Why would I bring that up?
I wonder if I can
pull off a flirty wink.
Nope, I can't.
How many siblings do you have?
Oh, I already asked that one.
I'm going to get us
both out of this.
I'm going get
an emergency work call
right now and never come back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This has been...
-And, finally,
people are talking about this.
At Paris Fashion Week,
Bella Hadid
had her dress painted on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was good, right?
Take a look at this.
♪♪
Yeah.
Amazing.
Yeah, when she walked
the runway, people didn't know
if she was a supermodel
or a Tesla robot.
We have a great show.